HEYYYY
Today, we're gonna play: Prey To The Gods.
You better pray to the gods this game is good!
(Mandatory pun)
Uh.. it's the spiritual successor to Shadow of the Colossus.
Which is one of the finest pieces of
*kisses fingers*
"game" you can find.
I'm sick by the way,
so in case I sound like I'm trying keep a sexy voice or some shit.
I'm-- I'm not.
Alright, I got an arrow.
Gimme that shit.
Now we have the bow and the arrow.
Which-- OHHHH- hey, let's practice.
Ok, let's hit the.. one in the middle.
OK, my mouse sensiti--
--HEY, you were supposed to shoot!
Alright, and... release!
No? Ok. Release and-- AHHH
I could potentially be the worse player at this game,
because I'm probably the only one that isn't a developer that played this game.
Badabip Badabip Badabip Badabip Badabip Badabip Badabip-
I think what- what really struck me with Shadow of the Colossus,
is how.. fucking impressive it is.
It like- It's a Playstation 2 game..
and it runs..
like (stutters) ...What it can do!
IS A LOT- IT'S B- IT'S GOOD
(Yes Pewds we get it)
It's good. It's good. Is what I'm trying to say. Thank you.
Alright, I'm just going to keep rolling cause I--
[terrifying growl] AHHHHHHHHH
Ahhhhahh, WHAT THE.. FUCK
ARE YOU?!
[High pitched roar]
Oh my God! Hey-
AHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
Oh my God, I shit myself
Bring it!
Bring it, man!
[Monster screaming]
AAHHHH! (Classic Swedish cursing)
Holy shit I'm a pussy
I think I got it
[Manly scream] Nope, did not.
Where are you? Where are you?
F- FUCK ME
They're scary, they're fucking scary, ok?! Holy shit
This is so immersive. I've been playing for just a couple minutes, but I'm well into this.
This is REALLY cool.
I am honestly not trying to oversell this, because I got to play it earlier, and you can't play the-
Look, it says "pre alpha 0.1 point ze--"
That means it's early.
Well, I think a storm is coming. This is
practically what it's like to live in Brighton!
I like how it borrows from uhh
Shadow of the colossus
but it's still very much it's own thing
Can I make a snow angel?
Obviously I am going to make a penis.
(Like any normal gamer would)
You can make a penis in the game. 10/10
Dude, that is so creepy. [echoing whisper, almost sigh]
The whispers is done really well. [Whispers continue]
This is actually creeping me out in DAYLIGHT.
You know what I mean? You know what I mean?
Don't tell me you're not shitting yourself right now, as well.
[Loud screech] Aaah, okay, I got him, got him, got him, got him, got him.
I didn't even flinch (Yeah right)
Eurghhhhh! Fuuuuuu
[Freaked out] I didn't know I was playing a fucking horror game, dude...
[Loud roar] Ah!
[More roars]
Missed me, BITCH!
[Roar]
OH! ...Dude. Actual goose bumps.
That is so intense! I love it.
[British accent] Is that fuckin' bacon?
Oh, cool! Of course there's climbing,
that's cool.
That's a big thing in the...
That other game that I mentioned about a million times.
Oh, I didn't see this before.
OH, they're NOT bacon!
(What made you think its bacon Pewds?)
They're firewood!
Wait, I can sleep!?
The very first IKEA bed, everyone.
So it plays more on the survival part. I think that's cool.
OK, what do we have-- THERE IT IS!
The grappling! That's awesome!
I got a fuckin' grappling hook!
How does it work? Green? OHHHHHHH! ...Yeahhh!
Wanna go down now. I'm scared...
I'm fucking this rock right now.
This rock is my fuckin' bitch, man.
(Nothing to see here)
Got the grappling hook.
Now let's head to the boss!
OOOHHH, OOH! It's happening. It's happening!
It's gonna come from the sky.
I'm sure of it.. Oh?
OOOOHHHHH, nevermind! It came from the fuckin' rocks!
Jesus!
Look at those man boobs!
We're going to shoot in the sensitive
area!
[Close up cause why the fuck not]
Now the other sensitive area!
In between the butt cheeks!
Got him!
HEYOO! And we are on!
Oh, this takes me back, man--
Ey, don't just walk, you crazy-
[Rocks crumbling]
We got to go to its head.
Don't mind me! I'm just, literally like a parasite on your body.
Oh, I gotta hold on. By clicking!
HOLD ON, GIRL!
HOLD ON, CHILD!
We're on. We're on. Ho-ly shit
I did it.
Okay, what happens now?
Wha??
This is unexpected.
Oh, okay.
'Kay, since it's a demo,
I'm guessing they're taking it away from
us.
Damn!
That was a lot better than I expected, that's really cool.
I still had pretty high expectations.
Alright, hope you enjoyed this gameplay.
If you did, leave a like, I appreciate it.
Thank you so much for watching and, as
always, stay awesome Bros!
Pewds: Michael.
Micheal: Yeah?
Pewds: Give my channel to Edgar.
Pewds: It's not worth it. It's not worth living on this planet.
I'm scared. *laughs*
(disgusted) He's not even wearing fucking gloves...
He's not even wearing gloves...